l'un des plus proches soutiens de
françois fillon est l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir bruno
retailleau dans ce soit michel grossiord
et merci d'être avec nous vous n'avez
jamais douté en effet jamais flancher un
dans votre fidélité votre appui au
candidat portait apparemment par une
dynamique de fin de campagne sénateur de
la vendée président du groupe l'est
républicain au sénat et président du
conseil régional des pays de la loire
vous répondrai au cours de cette
émission à trois grandes questions
émission de public sénat donc avec l'
agence france presse avec les échos et
radio classique d'abord le programme de
françois fillon n'est-il pas irréaliste
c'est ce que vous demandera jean-francis
pécresse arguments à l'appui vous verrez
ensuite la campagne qui s'achève
dimanche front telle une mauvaise
tournure avec le ton qui monte entre les
principaux candidats
c'est ce que vous demandera nadège pizza
qu'enfin le sénat at il déjà tourné la
page de la gauche ce que vous reproche
notamment votre homologue le président
des sénateurs socialistes didier
guillaume puisque vous refuser
d'examiner le budget présenté par le
gouvernement
voulu répondre et ainsi qu'à mickaël
szames est-ce qui vous interrogera par
ailleurs sur la candidature imminente
des manuels macron et si l'ancien
ministre de l'économie chercher à sa
manière à peser aussi sur la primaire de
la droite et du centre mais d'abord
bruno retailleau une première question
d'actualité
la justice administrative a donc donné
hier son feu vert juridique à l'aéroport
notre dame des landes
chacun doit maintenant respecter la
légalité du projet a répété tout à
l'heure manuel valls est ce que vous
croyez vraiment à l'arrivée des crs et
des gendarmes mobiles pourrait évacuer
le site
oui j'y crois d'abord je voudrais
replacer cette question dans un contexte
plus large il faut les reports pourquoi
il le faut parce que la bretagne les
pays de la loire nous sommes coude à
coude d'ailleurs avec jean yves le drian
sur ce sujet là nous sommes en bout du
bout de l'europe voilà avec un fort
développement économique et nous avons
besoin de connexion vous savez que en
2011 vous aviez six jours sur nantes
atlantique les reports actuelle six
jours de saturation en 2015 cinq ans
après un peu moins quatre ans après vous
en avez sans ne savait pas un rêve de
grandeur des infrastructures bébé
démentiel comme vous avez reproché aux
politiques de tous bords d'ailleurs pays
des averses
c'est là vers parce que entre la dlp la
déclaration d'utilité publique est
aujourd'hui en réalité on fait beaucoup
plus en terme de dynamique de trafic
donc de ce côté ci les choses ont été
confirmés maintenant l'évacuation les
vacations
bien sûr il faut les vacations 1 mais là
faut pour deux raisons me croyez bien
sûr il faut pour deux raisons le
président république s'est engagé il a
dit on fait un référendum
le référendum nous l'avons gagnée le oui
a gagné avec un verdict clair et net le
peuple s'est exprimé
et nous avons désormais 160 10 878
décision de justice qui vont toutes dans
le même sens alors moi je veux bien
qu'en france nous ne soyons plus dans un
état de droit c'est à dire que les
tribunaux parlent pour ne pas être avec
des décisions justice qui ne serait pas
exécutée je veux bien que ont recours à
la parole du peuple pour lui donner une
gifle c'est à dire pour ne pas exécuter
ce que les gens demandent ce serait
terrible pour la démocratie
ce serait terrible pour l'autorité de
l'état et j'espère je crois encore que
manuel valls a une certaine idée de
l'autorité de l'état
j'espère que le prénom de république à
qui appartient l'ultime décision
décidera de l'évacuer cette attaque est
une zone de non droit où des
journalistes sont attaqués alors les
scientifiques voulaient des gendarmes et
l'ordre ne vient toujours
je disais le premier ministre a parlé du
dossier il est sur votre ligne bien sûr
fondamentalement mais il est resté très
flou sur le calendrier il est resté flou
parce que j'imagine que le prix à dire
un public non j'imagine que le président
des raisons sont énormes il ya les
risques mais on me dit il ya des risques
il a dit rice oui est ce qu'il faut
c'est des chanteurs des autorités
publiques il ya le mort de sivens et
puis sur place il y a des gens qui se
sont organisés vraiment avec l'autre
jour il ya une répétition grandeur
nature 150 tracteurs un des pièges
il ya même des groupes qui sont formés à
l'autodéfense absolument ce sont des
ultraviolets un risque ce sera bien sûr
yen risque mais ce que la république
doit reculer à chaque fois qu'il ya un
risque
est ce qu'on doit céder au chantage non
la violence vient de celles et ceux qui
soutiennent les à dist elle pourrait
venir des as 10 mais j'ai bon espoir
j'espère que ce qui nous donne je parle
d'un certain nombre de personnalités
écologistes des leçons de morale sur la
démocratie et sur l'état de droit
j'espère que si demain l'état engage des
actions pour exécuter les décisions de
justice j'espère évidemment qu'ils se
rendront aux arguments paisible de la
démocratie de l'internaute prend pas le
chemin mais vous avez une idée du nombre
de gendarmes mobiles qu'il faudra
déployer sur le terrain on dit des
centaines publié en 1900 vous savez
combien y avait des gendarmes pour
protéger les chefs d'état qui sont venus
pour la coop 21
il ya plusieurs mois ils étaient plus de
10000 donc une action résolue de l'état
est possible et je pense que si demain
on veut que la zad devienne la base
arrière de toutes les guérillas urbaines
de toutes les oppositions à tous les
projets d'infrastructure qui bloquerait
l'économie française et développement de
la france alors laissons faire ce sera
terrible
vous y croyez encore il ya encore des
obstacles variés encore des recours et
demande d'accélérer d'obstacles européen
en est il que le droit l'environnement
sont bien sûr il vous la commission
européenne demande annuler ces documents
c'est de l'intoxication
j'ai entendu vos confrères il ya moins
de 48 heures d'hier il suffit de
rajouter 100 m à la piste actuelle pour
pouvoir avoir un aéroport qui pourrait
recevoir le trafic mais si c'était ça le
gros sur moi je prends un casque tout de
suite et je mets au volant je veux dire
d'un
there je le fais évidemment mais c'est
de l'intox malheureusement ce qui n'est
pas de l'intox c'est les 178 décision
des plus hauts tribunaux français cour
administrative d'appel conseil d'état
cour de cassation c'est ce qu'a
également rappelé aujourd'hui le premier
ministre alors après cette première
question d'actualité
la première partie de l'épreuve de
vérité avec jean francis pécresse le
directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique
france emond soir michel bonsoir bruno
retailleau bonsergent ipcress est ce que
le projet de votre candidat françois
fillon n'est pas au fond le plus et le
plus irréaliste de tous les projets des
candidats de la droite à la primaire
c'est au contraire le plus réaliste pour
redresser la france
ça fait 30 ans que les hommes politiques
français de gauche et de droite patauge
dans des demi-mesures ça fait 30 ans
qu'aucune majorité ne sut 6 et succéder
à elle-même ça fait 30 ans que la france
dégringole
ce que françois fillon veut faire c'est
en réalité ce que beaucoup de
gouvernements européens ont eu le
courage de faire et cela leur a permis
d'ailleurs de redresser leur pays
donc on va le détailler un peu vous
proposer la suppression de cinq cent
mille postes de fonctionnaires en cinq
ans ce qui signifie que globalement vous
n'embaucherait pas de fonctionnaires
pendant toute la durée du quinquennat
est ce que c'est réaliste ça parce que
votre calcul est faux pour deux raisons
sa celui aussi de certains des opposants
françois fillon fillon ont bien
l'intention tellement téléphoner irons
écouter l'argument tu es tellement
téléphoné je m'y attendais ce que
propose d'abord vous savez qu'on a plus
de 5 millions 500 mille fonctionnaires
on a la fonction publique la plus
nombreuse et dieu sait si les
fonctionnaires ce sont des gens
parfaitement respectable mais ils vivent
finalement une forme de paupérisation
parce que le nom fait que la nation ne
peut pas et on est obligé d'ailleurs de
d'emprunter pour payer les salaires ou
les retraites
ce que je veux dire c'est que deux
choses françois fillon propose de passer
à 39 heures pour la fonction publique ça
fait une quantité de travail vous savez
que de plus beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
puisque quand je suis arrivé dans ma
région
finalement je suis aperçu que les
collaborateurs travailler moins de 35
heures et pour beaucoup de collectivités
c'est le 39 heures ça fait une masse si
j'ose dire
deux heures de travail supplémentaires
et ensuite on oublie de dire qu'il ya à
peu près un million de fonctionnaires
qui partiront dans les cinq prochaines
années alors cinq cent mille
fonctionnaires peu près ou plutôt six
cent mille cent vingt mille par an à peu
près 170 maisons les plus purs esprits
les contractuels et les contractuels
c'est de l'ordre
ça veut dire que on ne remplace pas un
départ sur deux à la retraite c'est
parfaitement faisable c'est parfaitement
faisable d'autant plus qu encore une
fois on a une fonction publique qui est
une de celles qui la plus nombreuse
d'europe et des pays européens comme
l'allemagne qui en ont beaucoup moins
que nous ont des services publics qui
sont aussi très performant nous sommes
attachés au service public
mais je pense qu'il faut réorganiser le
travail de la fonction publique les
faire travailler plus ça coûte cher et
l'institut montaigne a calculé que par
exemple faire passer le temps de travail
dans la fonction publique de 35 à 39
heures ça vous coûterait 15 milliards
d'euros comment est-ce que vous financez
cela ce que propose françois fillon
c'est de proposer qu'une partie le
passage de 35 d'abord tout le monde pour
le même salaire doit travailler 35
heures quand ceux qui travaillent 32
heures ils sont payés pour 35 heures
première chose
deuxième chose ce que propose françois
fillon c'est que on puisse passer avec
une rémunération de 37 eur et cueilli
une négociation qui puisse s'engager
pour que l'on puisse accompagner les
carrières dans la fonction publique pour
que lorsque vous rentrez à 20 ans dans
une case
vous ne sachiez pas à 35 ou 37 ou
quarante ans plus tard à quel autre cas
vous serez vous pourriez avoir une
fluidité une perspective professionnelle
beaucoup plus rapide c'est des
négociations mais si on ne le fait pas
d'autres pays l'ont fait si on ne le
fait pas je pense que on ne pourra pas
faire des économies qui seront
significatives et ses cinq cent mille
postes ou est-ce que vous les supprimez
précisément parce que vous ne l'avez pas
dit françois fillon ne dit pas où est ce
que vous les supprimez donc en fonction
tant les on les supprime
en dehors des ministères régaliens ans
les supprime
on ne supprime pas dans la police on les
supprime pas un journal murray ni non
plus dans l'armée et du mali non plus
dans les hôpitaux avec un cynisme mais
vous savez que les hôpitaux les hôpitaux
ont été totalement si j'ose dire
désorganisé par les 35 heures ça se sait
c'est de notoriété publique
voilà donc je pense que de ce point de
vue il est évidemment pour l'éducation
nationale est-ce que vous pensez que
l'école en france aujourd'hui va mieux
avec un plus de cinq ans pile en soit
l'on s'était engagé il le fera pas
totalement à recruter 60 milles mais on
voit bien que dans notre système
jean-francis près qu'à ce que tout n'est
pas une question de moyens parce que
quand un système va mal plus vous
rajoutez des moyens et moins vous avez
de résultats est aujourd'hui l'école
vous pouvez si vous ne changez pas que
ce soit sur la pédagogie ou sur un
certain nombre d' approche pour donner
plus de liberté et d'autonomie
eh bien vous ne réglerez pas le problème
de ces jeunes qui par milliers des
dizaines de milliers quittent le système
scolaire sans savoir lire contexte et à
tous les ans ce qui veut dire en creux
que vous supprimerez bien des postes
dans l'éducation si françois fillon
était et est élu président de la
république à partir de mai 2010 est
absolument
ça n'est pas une approche de gauche vous
a pas approchés savannah pas comment
dirais je
j'ai appris sur l'exacte est ce que ça
veut dire que pour les fonctionnaires en
place vous ouvrir y ait un guichet
départ en quelque sorte parce que les
simples départ à la retraite dans
l'éducation ne suffiront pas à à à
absorber vos suppressions de postes si
puisque je vous le disais il ya quelques
instants vous avez tous les ans cent
vingt mille fonctionnaires qui quittent
sans voilà à peu près et vous avez quand
contractuels pratiquement 100 millions
ça ne se sait pas parce que les
contractuels il faut savoir dans toutes
les collectivités né à l'état aussi nous
employons des personnes qui ne sont pas
sous statut fonction publique qui sont
sous statut comptera donc vous avez tous
les ans donc 220 me à peu près qui
quitte donc on va pas chasser les gens
ils bénéficient d'un statut ce statut il
est protecteur
on souhaite simplement leur proposer de
meilleures évolutions de carrière de
travailler plus pour que y ait une
fonction publique qui soient moins
nombreuses parce que on ne le pays ne
peut plus se payer satisfait départ
c'est un détail c'est pas détaillé je
suis pas misé la fonction publique ça
fait 10 ans c'est ce qu'avait camelin
partenaires
nous explique les grands équilibres et
comment il compte y parvenir
autre élément peut-être vous préconisez
vous affirmez que vous ferez 100
milliards d'euros d'économies dans la
dépense publique d'ici à 2022 et
l'institut montaigne encore une fois qui
est un think tank dit on les a pas
retrouvées dans le projet de françois
fillon on en a trouvé 80 milliards au
mieux je suis désolé françois fillon
s'est alors je suis désolé je je peux
demander à l'équipe de françois fillon
de transmettre à monsieur bigard qui est
le directeur de l'institut montaigne le
chiffrage de françois fillon le françois
pignon est sans doute le candidat qui a
chiffré le plus précisément ses
économies et ses économies tiennent à
des économies sur l'ensemble si j'ose
dire non seulement des trois fonctions
publiques mais des trois grands comptes
aussi bien sur les collectivités
territoriales aussi bien sur la sécurité
sociale et enfin sur l'état sur les
grands mission de l'aider ou est ce que
vous y connaissez s'allumant jusqu'au et
bien il ya vous savez parfaitement que
il ya une évolution naturelle de la
dépense
voilà y compris lorsque on parlera sans
doute tout à l'heure du budget mais à ce
budget là monsieur hollande avait prévu
de nous faire des économies et bien
malgré tout il y aura 7 milliards de
dépenses qui vont déraper en plus
et bien quand vous annulé cette
évolution naturelle vous obtenez avec
les économies faites sur la fonction
publique comme je vous le disais sur les
collectivités locales la sécurité
sociale aussi bien les retraites parce
que c'est là qu'on va gagner le plus
avec la retraite à 65 ans voilà avec un
certain nombre de rationalisation
puisqu'aujourd'hui on a un système de
santé qui totalement hospital au centre
et c'est à dire que on a une des pentes
de la santé qui coûte très très cher
c'est parce que souhaite françois fillon
est bien au bout du bout on aura les 100
milliards sur sur cinq ans alors vous
avez dit il ya un instant que ça fait 30
ans que les hommes politiques et
responsables pato jour n'a envie de dire
peut-être françois fillon lui-même un
bizuth alain juppé critique aujourd'hui
ce qui gonfle leurs biceps
après avoir été prise il ya nîmes au
pouvoir il a notamment ciblé hier soir
au zénith
nicolas sarkozy mais le matin c'était
françois fillon qui était visé il ne
suffit pas de bomber le torse pour être
réaliste et pour pouvoir tenir ses
engagements est ce que il est
franchement alors franchement
aujourd'hui même touraine bomber le
torse pour dire voilà les retraites et
que c'était à quels sont les deux
réformes qui ont produit le plus
d'économies
la réforme de 2003 françois fillon la
réforme de 2010 françois fillon
alors bien sûr que il a été premier
ministre
avec un président de république nicolas
sarkozy tout n'a pas été fait mais il
n'était pas présent république
si ce n'est que lorsqu'il a eu des
responsabilités à prendre et je me
souviens très bien
les millions personnes dans la rue pour
ses réformes
eh bien ça ne l'a pas fait reculer donc
je crois que non françois fillon est un
homme constant et c'est une des grandes
qualités qui sont en train aujourd'hui
de découvrir les français est-ce qu'il
est constant aussi dans sa promesse
d'augmentation d'impôts on se souvient
qu'à la fin du quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy il ya eu de fortes augmentations
d'impôts pour les ménages
- pour les entreprises mais pour les
ménages beaucoup aidé dans son projet
encore une fois il ya une augmentation
de la tva de deux points
est ce que la droite peut revenir au
pouvoir en 2017 avec une promesse
d'augmenter vous savez sur les ménages
et en particulier parce que c'est de la
tva sur les ménages modestes d'un an
vous savez parfaitement les exemples
européens qui ont pratiqué cette
augmentation de tva ça ne s'est pas
traduit par des prix plus chers parce
que lorsque vous commentez la tva et je
vais vous dire pourquoi on l'a fait vous
diminuer les cotisations sociales
donc finalement c'est un jeu à somme
nulle pour les salariés par ailleurs
c'est la seule façon d'obtenir une
mesure six jours dire protectionnistes
qui permet sur chaque importation de
payer sur chaque importation la sécurité
sociale des français et c'est en même
temps quelque chose qui ne sera pas
supporté par les exportations donc on
gagne en compétitivité puisque vous
baisser le coût du travail et on gagne
en protection puisque vous faites
contribuer les importations au déficit
de la sécurité sociale
c'est donc très
vertueux c'est la raison pour laquelle
françois fillon a proposé cette mesure
voilà et l'allemagne tous les grands
pays nordiques l'on ferait avec la nôtre
qui est moins élevé qu'à nous on est à
vingt et quelques pourcents rafah ont
été diversement
ce qui est important c'est que ce qu'ils
ont facilement pris à la tv là il faut à
due concurrence
évidemment baisser les cônes ans et
s'offre aussi à l'aise sur les tracés la
cpa mais sur l'impôt sur le revenu
françois fillon n'en fait pas du tout
une priorité alors là vous vous avez
passé votre temps ces dernières années à
taper sur le gouvernement commenter les
impôts elle avoue souhaiter un candidat
qui dit oh je suis pas sûr des touchés
par ce qui fait un choix
son choix c'est que le cancer de la
société française c'est le chômage de
masse
si on veut diminuer le chômage de masse
il faut que nos entreprises retrouvent
de la compétitivité et donc le choix
qu'il fait c'est d'affecter à peu près
10 milliards de moins sur les ménages
l'impôt notamment sur les familles qui
ont été sur fiscalisés françois hollande
s'est acharné sur les familles je vais
dire comme aucun président de la
république comme aucun y compris de
gauche est en revanche bien sûr mais
laissez moi juste terminer ce que je
vais dire et vous accueillera dans le
final c'est ça va la wii et
parallèlement 40 milliards pour que les
entreprises puissent retrouver de la
compétitivité le quotient familial choix
il est rétabli quand et à quel niveau il
est rétabli dès l'année 2010 est il est
rétabli il est rétabli sur 'niveau
colère yoff sur un collectif et il est
rétabli au niveau antérieur puisque vous
avez eu à 2012 un absolument vous avez
de deux augmentations
voilà pour françois hollande sur la
politique familiale
merci merci merci et ses vêtements
nadège peljak de l'agencé france presse
qui nous rejoint bruno retailleau il
épreuve de vérité avait
bonsoir nadège est boussois michel émond
soir monsieur retailleau bon surnomme
alors accompagné ce qu'on peut dire
qu'elle prend une mauvaise tournure
non mais vous savez nous la droite c'est
pas notre culture un le primaire moi je
trouve ces primaires ce n'est pas de
votre cuisse et sa garde culture c'est
la première fois qu'on fait une primaire
bah c'est une compétition compétition
entre des hommes une femme compétition
entre des tempéraments des caractères
ils sont forts c'est normal et puis les
compétitions avec des idées des projets
enfin les esprits s'échauffent quand
sarkozy qui critiquent juppé juppé qui
critiquent fillon fillon qui critiquent
sarkozy alors que tout le monde en prend
pour son grade comme ça oui mais ça
reste franchement ça reste dans les
limites du raisonnable et si c'est
limite est franchie nous avons la haute
lande est normal de compétition mais
bien sûr beau bien sûr évidemment vous
le savez bien d'accord et il le deuxième
débat il aura lieu il a eu lieu par dont
le deuxième débat il a été plus sportif
que le premier on peut dire ça comme ça
le troisième qui aura lieu rue donc lieu
jeudi soir vous en attendez quoi jeu
j'en attends de la clarté
voilà ce que veulent les français se
sont pas des chicayas vous avez
parfaitement raison il ne faut pas ça
devait c'est justement à ces querelles
de caniveau ces chorales de cour de
récréation
les français ont besoin de savoir parce
que moi je pense profondément que en
la france va voir rendez vous avec son
histoire en clair la france est en train
de dégringoler
on peut comparer notre pays chômage
déficit endettement etc avec les autres
pays européens nous dégringolons donc on
a rendez vous avec notre histoire parce
que si on ne reprend pas la maîtrise le
destin est bien là des red lights sera
une glissade
je pense que il faut le sérieux et les
candidats tous les candidats doivent le
sérieux aux français en exprimant un peu
comme ça que vous voudrez arij réagi à
droite comme à gauche du sort je vais
d'ailleurs candidat il devra lui aussi
pour prendre notre destin en main et
puis c'est toujours le non non non non
non parce que là on va t'en prends des
cantons va atteindre 100% de la dette
par rapport à la richesse nationale les
taux vont commencer à augmenter et donc
qu'il va y avoir un mécanisme de boules
de neige qui peut être fatale
vraiment pour l'économie française
non je pense que l'heure est grave il
faut prendre des mesures qui soient des
mesures des vraies mesures
c'est pour ça que il faut pas d encore
une fois des demies projet de réforme
il faut enfin parce qu'avant de passer à
la présidence caleçon en causera plus
tard et donc on sait que le troisième
débat aura lieu jeudi
ensuite après ce débat là faudra bien se
rassembler et c'est vrai qu'on a quand
même un petit peu des doutes parce que
si je lis bien françois fillon alors
alain juppé ce clan tony's il dit juppé
il suffit pas de bomber le torse et j'en
passe et des meilleurs enfin tout cas ma
part mais les meilleurs il ya la
déclaration aujourd'hui de jean françois
copé qui ciblent directement françois
fillon vous l'avez nul il part d'une
imposture fillon a une si longue absence
d'ambiguïté puisque ton qu'on le disait
tout à l'heure il a été au pouvoir une
imposture car comment réagissez vous à
ce mot de jean françois copé je ne tombe
pas dans ce genre de travers je pense
que les français attendent autre chose
que ce genre de petite phrase et je
pense que le débat doit rester digne
voilà il doit rester digne et je pense
très très franchement si françois fillon
a gagné les deux débats c'est par sa
dignité et je pense parce que vous
pensez qu'il a gagné parce que selon les
sondages vous l'avenir les sondages mais
quand même ça veut dire quelque chose et
son âge de temps en temps un quand
fillon monte on dirait on en parlera
aussi tout à l'heure bon si vous voulez
soulage s'est pas fait cesser juppé qui
avait gagné les deux les deux premiers
débats à risque en tout cas c'est un en
tout cas ce qui est clair vous le savez
très bien moi je me méfie des sondages
ce qui est important c'est dans les 60
les dynamiques nommé ce sont ces la
dynamique c'est toujours la même chose
c'est pas le niveau absolu que donne aux
sondages c'est vraiment ce que les série
de sondages plusieurs sondages ajoutés
les uns aux autres donnent comme
dynamique et vous savez très bien que la
dynamique de françois fillon date
précisément du premier débat pourquoi
parce que les français ont découvert un
homme qui est sincère qui est droit et
qui a une hauteur de vue et qui ne
succombent pas justement à la tentation
des petits ajustements la dynamique pour
monsieur fillon est excellente on le
voit jour après jour dans tous les
sondages parce qu'ils sont attendus
d'ailleurs qui pourrait effectivement
annoncé un c'est ce qu'ont
mon de la fourchette c'est ce qu'on nous
dit est donc c'est une surprise mais
vous voilà qu'est ce que vous avez dû
renoncer pas une surprise évidemment non
j'ai dit simplement depuis plusieurs
jours plusieurs semaines que françois
fillon serait la surprise du premier
tour des primaires pourquoi parce que
justement je pense qu'il à cette hauteur
de vue il a ce calme cette sérénité une
constance et surtout parce que je pense
qu'il est la bonne synthèse entre d'un
côté le volontarisme la détermination de
nicolas sarkozy mais sans le côté trop
clivant et en même temps la sérénité
dallas votre avis il prend des points
acquis à juppé voit sarkozy je pense
qu'il en prend aux deux je pense qu'il
en prend aussi à bruno le maire je pense
qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui il ya des
électeurs des français qui ne savaient
pas comment voter qui commencent à
s'intéresser tout juste à la primaire
vous savez les sondeurs et il nous faut
un coup à chaque fois comme par hasard
les choses se resserrent toujours
toujours à la dernière seconde
bon voilà trop les sondages parce que je
suis sceptique pas ici réa bhl est ce
que je veux dire c'est que là les
sondeurs dans une difficulté qu'il faut
quand même pas je veux dire négliger
c'est qu'on n'a jamais sondés on sait la
primaire elle n'a jamais eu lieu on
connaît corps électoral entre eux n'est
pas le corps électoral
et en plus il ya beaucoup de rapine dans
l'est des électeurs de droite à gauche
ou de gauche à droite d'habitude
et là c'est dans une même famille donc
cette fluidité ce zapping là est encore
plus important mais c'est clair qu'il ya
une dynamique
je vais vous dire deux ou trois exemples
moi je suis françois fillon sur un
certain nombre de manifestations l'autre
jour c'était la vendée on avait
pratiquement 1500 personnes
les réseaux sociaux ils dominent
largement et je vais vous annoncer ce
soir que il fait son grand meeting c'est
au palais des congrès voilà vendredi et
bien la selle est tellement plein qui va
falloir louer une autre salle pour
pouvoir
comment dirais-je faire en sorte que
tout le monde tout le monde en plus tout
le monde il devra se partager on est en
train de travailler justement sur le
partage puisqu'il n'a pas le don
d'ubiquité encore encore encore qu'est
ce qui nous attend alors est-ce que son
livre vaincre le totalitarisme islamiste
est pour quelque chose on s'en remet à
j'espère parce que c'est un livre dont
on a souvent
bien aller en voilà c'est aussi un autre
indice moi je pense c'est vraiment ma
conviction depuis des mois et des mois
je pense que l' angoisse française le
pessimisme français c'est deux choses
c'est la peur du déclassement économique
le chômage mais en même temps la peur
une autre paire c'est la dépossession
identitaire et moi je m'inscris pas je
ne choisis pas l'un ou l'autre il faut à
la fois lutter contre le chômage
mais il faut être extrêmement ferme
parce qu'il ya la barbarie il ya le
terrorisme islamique et on a un vrai
sujet avec une dérive politique de
l'islam
il faut nommer c'est pape les
catholiques c'est pas les protestants
s'est pas non plus les juifs où le
bouddhisme qui pose problème c'est une
partie une partie je veux dire des
musulmans qui se font convainc slam
radical alheureusement par un
radicalisme
moi je connais avion pour nommer la
communauté musulmane il
il l'a fait l'autre jour d'ailleurs non
est ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
on me situer tout à l'heure le
l'institut montaigne
quand cet institut nous montre que parmi
cette communauté 28% place la charia au
dessus des lois de la république
alors là il ya un problème et je pense
que françois fillon est un de ceux en
tout cas je pense une même le seul qui a
une bonne réponse de ce point de vue là
alors donc il est d'ailleurs largement
dans son livre dans son livre et l'autre
jour en meeting à biarritz il a évoqué
effectivement la communauté musulmane
qui se laisse gong rennais bah oui alors
pas pu leur addition bien sûr une
tension c'est-à-dire tous les cas alors
autres infos pratiques
il ya une pratique de l'islam qui peut
être une pratique respectueuse des lois
de la république
mais quand on place la charia au dessus
des lois d'un public ça c'est
inacceptable et il faut être implacables
les imams qui prêchent la haine et bien
c'est dehors il faut évidemment une
contrainte administrative françois
fillon l'expriment et l'expliquent très
bien dans son livre qui ne laisse
justement aucune porte d'entrée à ce
genre de salafistes du wahhabisme en
tout cas de radicalisation de l'islam
autres propos remarqué il ya quelques
jours à biarritz toujours françois
fillon qui s'est présenté en quelque
sorte n'a déjà comme le monsieur propre
de la primaire c'est ce qu'il a dit donc
lors de ce meeting en écoute
j'entends beaucoup d'hommes politiques
m'expliquer que les hommes politiques
comme les citoyens
ils ont droit à la présomption
d'innocence ils ont droit à une deuxième
chance mais nous ne sommes pas des
citoyens comme les autres
comment est-ce qu'on peut être les
gardiens de la justice et des
institutions
si on a soi même des difficultés avec la
justice et la police
on a compris dans quel jardin a ajouté
sa pierre là même son groupe avait oui
alors c'est vrai que monsieur fillon il
se présente un petit peu comme le
monsieur propre
lui il n'a pas été condamné suivez mon
regard comme monsieur juppé il n'a pas
été mise en examen
suivez mon regard comme monsieur sarkozy
il a raison de jouer sur ces thèmes là
non en tout cas il a raison d'affirmer
que les hommes politiques doivent être
exemplaires doivent être droit honnête
pourquoi parce qu'on voit bien ce qu'on
appelle le populisme on voit bien ce
doute profond dans toutes les
démocraties occidentales on voit que il
ya une perte de confiance entre les
peuples et ceux qui sont censés les
représenter
les élus évidemment si vous avez des
affaires à répétition ça pose des
problèmes donc françois il a l'air de
dire qu'il ya des candidats qui sont
disqualifiés absolument pas c'est
absolument faux moi je me c'est comme ça
je comprends quand faut il non mais il a
il donne un principe général est ce
qu'on peut donner un principe qui serait
inverse
il serait bon que les hommes politiques
aient des problèmes avec la justice pour
pouvoir se présenter
non voilà donc ils réaffirment quelque
chose qui est de l'ordre du bon sens
c'est un principe qui ne vise personne
et il faut que chacun s'applique à être
exemplaire dans son domaine
alors alors quelques jours de la
primaire toujours sur le rayon au rayon
des affaires un adage il ya les
nouvelles déclarations de l'homme
d'affaires ziad takieddine qui aurait
donc donné de l'argent libyen il le
raconte fois changer des vies ces
dernières années alors qu'il raconte en
tous les cas trois valises pour un total
de 5 millions d'euros à claude guéant
est directement à nicolas sarkozy pour
la campagne de 2007 on les écoute
dénoncer et qualifié un système se
qualifie de monsieur bruce et même la
mafia même la mafia était un peu plus
respectueuse que ça mais quelles
responsabilités
donnez-vous à monsieur sarkozy dans ce
que vous appelez vous cet état mafieux
la tête aujourd'hui
n'est ce pas lui qui est rappelé à ses
chirac jacques chirac est devenu à côté
de lui un saint nicolas sarkozy à
quelques instants opposé un démenti
formel et il annonce des poursuites
judiciaires comment vous réagissez quand
vous entendez cela aucune réaction je
moi je ne connais pas monsieur tadié
clean
je n'ai jamais rencontré et je n'ai
aucun commentaire à faire sur ce genre
de propos qui me paraît très très
excessif et à pégomas un monsieur qui a
plusieurs fois changé d'avis donc moi je
préfère qu'on en revienne encore une
fois à la primaire c'est vraiment bon
truc goyer est le vote fillon vous
dirais que c'est plutôt un vote pour ou
à votre contre les livres les électeurs
qui vont s'y retiens je vais aller voter
fillon pourquoi qu'est ce qu'ils font
ils ne veulent plus de sarkozy ils ne
veulent plus d'eux ils ne veulent pas
encore de juppé ils ne veulent pas de
jupe et elle résume à trois points se
retrouve pourquoi pas sion fillon c'est
la ligne droite il n'y a pas de coup de
volant à droite n'y a pas de coup de
volant à gauche il ya un cap
il est constant c'est vraiment avec la
vision pour vous êtes un vote de
conviction dès le premier tour il faut
voter pour ses convictions parce que il
ya la primaire et demain il y aura la
présidentielle et je pense que françois
fillon est le mieux à même à la fois de
battre la gauche est de battre le front
national parce qu'il a un projet qui est
un projet vraiment qui correspond à
l'adn de la droite
voilà sur la liberté sur l'autorité sans
oublier les valeurs
voilà c'est pas quelqu'un qui considère
que la droite c'est la gauche sans les
35 heures ça c'est l'adn l'egypte et
c'est ce que voulait dire la fin non pas
du tout pas du tout les à chaque fois
vous me ramener à tel ou tel moi
j'essaie d'exprimer des principes et
voilà je pense que fillon c'est un cap
une boussole
j'en parle d'autant mieux que ce
quinquennat actuel a commencé avec le
pédalo se termine avec le titanic
heureusement il ya vendée globe marc
alors ainsi devant des spectateurs assis
le vendée globe mais il faut nous et
s'alimenter dans la ville fois une
boussole il faut un cap
mais françois villon il a ce cap voilà
et je voudrais faire enfin pour le
vendée globe au sia et ben oui
avant du commun nous avait écoutés
monsieur jean pierre raffarin ce matin
qui a dit un joli fillon est dans le
piège la vème république parce qu'il a
été premier ministre de sarkozy il ne
peut pas battre monsieur sarkozy parce
que sarkozy était président alors qu'est
ce que vous dites est monsieur raffarin
lui dire a failli
ok y'a pas de songer à dire vous me
renvoyez ajouté mais non mais il n'y a
pas de loi il n'y a pas de loin tangi
vous le savez bien c'est les français
qui font les élections c'est pas des
lois qui sont écrites dans des livres au
préalable c'est une évidence et je crois
que françois fillon est en train de
démontrer que cette loi n'existe pas en
réalité ce qui compte aujourd'hui c'est
l'homme qui a la bonne hauteur de vue
qui a les convictions et qui aura la
constance d'appliquer un vrai projet et
pas des demi mesures parce que la france
a besoin de ce projet merci mais je
dernière partie de preuves par 3
maintenant avec michael jamesse de
public sénat qui nous rejoint
bonsoir michaëlle jean michel bourse en
mono retailleau en sommes qu sms est ce
que le sénat a déjà tourné la page de la
gauche non jeu on a en aimerait bien
vous savez pas ce que je pense que ce
quinquennat est un quinquennat
douloureux pour la france et pour les
français bien sûr mais c'est l'échec sur
tous les plans garder sur le chômage on
nous avait dit inversion de la courbe
on a plus six cent mille chômeurs de
plus on nous avait dit l'endettement
sera jugulé on aura bientôt on est à
plus de 98% bientôt à 100 % de la
richesse nationale
le déficit voilà on nous avait dit non
mais dès 2017 les choses qu'on contenu
c'est faux donc et sur les impôts c'est
pareil même d'ailleurs la rapporteure
socialiste à l'assemblée nationale dit
qu'il y aura les français vont payer
encore plus d'impôts aux entreprises et
ménages confondues c'est l'échec
votre réponse ce soir sur un fait
examinerez vous ou pas le projet de loi
de finances au sénat nous en déciderons
demain matin première chose
ce projet de loi de finances a été
depuis des jours et des jours travaillés
par la commission des finances et
notamment par le rapporteur général du
budget albéric de montgolfier et demain
matin nous ferons un point nous avons
deux hypothèses où nous le rejetons
parce que il posait problème
c'est une mascarade 106 il a été examiné
mais longuement des heures et vous
n'imaginez pas vous spécialiser mi6 non
mais vous savez parfaitement que le
travail essentiel au sénat c'est un
travail qui se fait ou dit dans les
commissions
mais c'est un travail essentiel
attendait et si vous voulez je pourrais
poser ici sur cette table un document
qui fit des centimètres et cm
d'épaisseur ça c'est la première
hypothèse verrait peut-être on va
jusqu'à la première partie et on leur
jette aux premières parties mais quel
est le problème justement il n'est pas
question que le gouvernement demande au
sénat de lui garantir ce que le haut
conseil finances publiques a dénoncé on
a non pas pour la première fois mais on
a un budget qui est un enfumage qui est
un budget électoral un budget de
campagne
un budget qui est tellement un sincère
que vous allez dans ce budget 20
5 milliards d'euros de dépenses qui
s'appliqueront après 2017
c'est terrible on s'en voulait pour vous
voulez pas l'examiner m'a écouté d'ores
et déjà quelle que soit la décision
enfin on attend votre décision demain
bruno retailleau mais déjà le président
des sénateurs socialistes je me disais
tout à l'heure didier guillaume
s'adresse à vous directement il va
jusqu'à évoquer une forfaiture
non cher bruno la responsabilité que tu
as comme président du groupe l'est
républicain laisse de côté la
présidentielle laisse de côté la
primaire de la droite et du centre
et dis toi bien que l'acte que vous
allez commettre là la forfaiture que
ceux des commettre en ne faisant pas
travailler le sénat où nous les français
dans un populisme qui peut aller très
très loin pense que les parlementaires
ne font rien ne travaille pas au moment
où le rôle essentiel d'un parlementaire
d'un sénateur
c'est de voter la loi et c'est de voter
le budget si tu as du pouvoir dans le
groupe politique
si tu as vraiment si tu as envie de
porter le sénat très haut
alors vas-y indique que nous allons
débattre sur le budget il est encore
temps doivent encore une semaine
mon cher bruno tu as entre les mains je
pense une partie de l'avenir du sénat tu
as entre les mains vraiment la façon de
montrer si les élus sont responsables
ou pas bruno tu as entre les mains
l'avenir d'un débat politique serein
alors votre réponse
c'est sympathie de la part de jean
guillaume de me donner autant de pouvoir
ils parlent de forfaiture
moi je pourrais parler de forfaiture
quand un président république en se
confiant des journalistes d'ailleurs sur
votre actuaires chose deuxième chose sur
le budget moi je me situe pas ni par
rapport à didier guillaume que je
respecte
évidemment je me situe par rapport aux
français ce qu'on nous demande là c'est
de voter un budget truc est mensonger
comme jamais un budget ne l'a été à vous
vous placez au sein du jamais l'avis du
sénat il le dit vous allez affaiblir
sénat ce qui affaiblit la parole
publique
c'est un théâtre d'ombrés où on discute
de choses qui sont totalement irréel
totalement truqué d'avancé quand vous
avez dit
migaud qui préside le kate à l'époque
était un député socialiste
on va pas dire que didier migaud est un
suppôt de la droite didier migaud
qu'est ce qu'il a dit il n'a cessé de
répéter que ce budget insincère que la
partie recettes avaient été surestimées
que la partie à cause des surestimations
notamment de la croissance dont vous
avez la patience pour dépenses mais non
mais vous en décembre
par contre il faut dire où vous dit la
primaire elle s'est invitée chez vous et
vous mr le problème de la primaire n'a
rien à voir ok on a un président de
république et on a un gouvernement qui
tente de nous faire avaler ce qui
ressemble à un tract de kobudo miquel
crs non je veux dire pourquoi non on ne
peut pas et vous le savez parfaitement
parce qu'il est l'article 40 qui nous
interdit de créer des charges
supplémentaires ou qui nous interdit
d'enlever des recettes c'est le
parlementarisme rationnalisé de la vème
république et par conséquent avec cet
article là les parlementaires sont
empêchés de construire un vrai contre
burget on ne peut pas le faire par
conséquent il nous reste deux solutions
on tranchera demain mais il est inquiet
servira pour vous il n'est pas question
qu'elle souhaiteriez-vous voir adopter
comme solution attendant personnel vous
êtes président du groupe à moi je pense
qu une question préalable je pense que
on prend les français à témoin et on dit
en français nous n'apporterons pas le
sénat et cette assemblée de sages avec
une distance politique vraiment vraiment
n'apporteront pas notre caution à un
budget qui est tellement un sincère
qu'il a été dénoncé
de part et d'autre le sénat comme
laboratoire de l'alternance c'est un peu
fini
ah non au contraire là vous l'autre
comment voulez vous que je vous je suis
en train de vous dire que avec l'article
on ne peut pas avoir un contre budget et
vous voudriez qu'on vote un budget de
gauche et qui étaient truquées par ce
gouvernement qui est totalement à sa
serre c'est parce que veulent les gens
les gens je crois veulent des choses
nette et claire dans la vie où ce budget
il est bon et on se précipite comme
didier guillot c'est normal c'est le
patron du groupe socialiste
ici au sénat eh ben il voudrait qu'on le
vote tous d'un même bien sûr je le
comprends sauf que ce budget là il sera
jamais appliquée et ce budget là il y en
a jamais eu d'aussi toxiques sous la
vème république retailleau emmanuel
macron va se porter candidat demain il
va l'annoncer aux alentours de 10h30
est ce que ça peut peser dans le scrutin
à droite d'abord ce que je veux dire
c'est que le fait même que cet ancien
ministre ancien conseiller très proche
de françois hollande songe à se
présenter
signe les chèques bien sûr du président
de république
ça c'est une évidence et je crois que il
veut faire coup double il veut d'abord
sur sa gauche empêché le président
république comme d'autres de se
représenter
et ils voudraient aussi sur sa droite ou
le centre capter l'électorat de françois
bayrou de france ouagadougou juppé ni
droite ni gauche donc je pense qu'il
fait effectivement ce calcul de la
captation à la fois d'un héritage sur sa
gauche et en même temps d'un
positionnement de françois bayrou qui a
toujours affirmé que son positionnement
c'était le ni droite ni qu'est-ce qu'ils
capturent quelque part le troisième
débat de la primaire ce qui va
l'annoncer la veille
mais je crois pas non c'est de la petite
politique siège d'accord rien qu'au de
beer d'une bande alors pour moi
justement ça c'est trop intelligent pour
moi parce que je ne sais pas ce que ça
vaudra d'être sérieux c'est pas que je
vais dire les français faut faire ce que
je souhaite c'est qu'un jour il puisse
être élu et sur son nom mais quand on
fait du terrain c'est parce que nous
demande des gens les gens sont en train
de nous dire on va faire un truc qu'on
finit d'ailleurs par perdre de vue sur
lesquels on finit par son bobine est soi
même
non ça c'est la politique politicienne
je pense qu'il ya des attentes et des
douleurs des souffrances des français et
il faut dire exactement quel est le
projet candidat sérieux ou pas candidat
sérieux c'est un homme sérieux emmanuel
macron je suis quelqu'un que je respecte
mais je doute très franchement de sa
capacité il est en opposition totale
avec l'adn de la gauche française et par
conséquent il n'a pas non plus à droite
les électeurs de droite préféreront
toujours un projet clair vous avez
françois fillon au sénat vous
déposer une proposition de résolution
pour faire reconnaître les crimes de
guerre crimes contre l'humanité et
crimes de guerre
quand est-ce qu'elle sera voté cette
résolution
elle sera examinée j'espère voter
d'ailleurs au mois de décembre prochain
je pense qu on est à un moment où il va
falloir juger les responsables de crimes
contre l'humanité même de génocide
ban ki moon le secrétaire général de
l'onu a qualifié d'ailleurs ces crimes
in compris de crimes contre l'humanité
et de génocides sur l'état islamique les
choses sont claires et je souhaite que
le sénat prenne ses responsabilités
parce que nous portons une idée qu est
une idée très forte car on ne peut pas
se taire
vis à vis de ce qui se passe visé des
chrétiens d'orient vis-à-vis des
minorités yazidi ou autre alors on a
parlé beaucoup de la primaire au cours
de cette émission vous n'avez jamais
perdu le sourire je vais vous le rendre
encore plus radieux peut-être puisqu'il
ya ce sondage qui vient de tomber pour
le site atlantico bruno retailleau qui
montrent une forte hausse de françois
fillon +10 points et qui serait donc en
fait au premier tour en coude à coude
avec nicolas sarkozy et il l'emporterait
au second aussi bien face à alain juppé
quel ancien chef de l'état comment
est-ce que vous réagissez est ce que
c'est un sondage donc les images sont
pas les suffrages je réagis comme
françois pourrait faire c'est à dire
avec la tête froide
en tout cas j'ai une certitude c'est que
ce sera la surprise je l' ai déjà dit
écrit a déjà plusieurs semaines et
plusieurs jours et que quel que soit
celui qui sera contre lui au deuxième
tour soit nicolas sarkozy soit alain
juppé yb altra l'un ou l'autre voilà il
sera donc vainqueur voilà et je pense
que dimanche il sera qualifié pour le
deuxième tour parce que le deuxième tour
encore pour le premier tour les français
devront faire un choix qui d'abord un
choix de conviction
voilà et c'est ce qu'il faut leur dire
rien n'est fait rien n'est joué
les français sont un peuple libre eh
bien ils doivent prendre cette liberté
et voter pour le candidat de leur choix
avec de vraies réformes pour redresser
la france où vous n'avez jamais douté de
votre champion m'a écouté j'ai du nord
il a toujours été rejoints à keita
catégorique sur le thème je serai au
second tour mais vous est ce que vous
avez eu des moments de doute est ce qu
il a pu vous réconforter
certainement il a toujours été déterminé
franchement il m'a étonné parce que vous
avez quand les sondages le plaçaient
très très bas vous 4e quatrième homme
d'ailleurs
il n'a jamais douté je pense qu'il a
travaillé et on le voit bien dans un
débat le fait de travailler ça permet de
surclasser finalement des concurrents ça
permet d'avoir une aisance et ça permet
finalement d'avoir pour les français les
meilleures garanties pour que la france
puisse se relever enfin merci merci
michael merci bruno retailleau la
semaine prochaine c'est gérard larcher
le président du sénat qui sera à votre
place donc dans l'antre de tours qui
s'annonce passionnant de cette primaire
bonsoir à tous et à très vite